let's all eat code 128 longest
consecutive sequence this is a pretty
interesting problem and it's actually
been asked by a lot of companies
including Google for a coding interview
so I think it's a good problem to
understand so we're given an input array
of numbers right in this case we have
six numbers and we want to find the
longest consecutive sequence in this
case the longest consecutive sequence is
one two three four right
it doesn't matter what order of the
numbers appear in and the input array we
just want to know the longest
consecutive sequence that we can make
from the input array now the most
obvious way to solve this problem is
just by sorting right so if you look at
the sorted array over here we have
obviously one consecutive sequence of
length four right one two three four
they're all consecutive numbers we also
have another one that's length one just
100 and we have the last one that's also
length one just 200 right now this is
definitely a valid solution we can
definitely code this up but the time
complexity is going to be o n log n so
the question is can we do better so this
is a leak code hard obviously the
solution wouldn't be this simple so we
can do better but how do we get there
now the first thing to do is try to
visualize the problem in a way that it
makes the problem really easy to
understand so I visualized the problem
by drawing out an imaginary number line
right so we can kind of see what the
sequences actually look like this makes
it a lot easier to recognize the
patterns so we know we have one sequence
that starts at one two three and four we
have another sequence that comes after
it with just one number 100 we have the
last sequence with also only one number
200 so just by looking at it we can tell
we have three distinct sequences right
that's something to recognize now by
visualizing it we can kind of try to
approach how would a human solve it well
the easiest way is just look at each of
the sequences right and count how long
they are
so let's look at the first sequence
right we have one two three and four so
this sequence has four numbers in it we
have the second sequence just 100 so it
only has one number in it so it's a
sequence of length 1 the last one is
also a sequence of length 1 now this is
so easy to solve when you visualize it
and try to approach it how a human would
but can we actually convert this into
code somehow the answer is yes so the
most important thing to notice is that
we have three sequences but how can we
identify what makes a sequence how can
we actually start at the beginning of a
sequence the thing to notice and this is
really easy when you actually look at
the picture that each sequence has a
start value the start value in this case
the start value for the first range or
the first sequence has no left neighbour
the first value 1 has no left neighbour
right that's really obvious look at the
second range 100 it doesn't have a left
neighbour the third range 200 doesn't
have a left neighbour so we can get the
start of each sequence by just looking
at our entire array of numbers right and
figuring out which numbers don't have a
left neighbour so meaning if we were if
we wanted to check if one had a left
neighbour we would check does our array
contain the number 0 if we wanted to
know if 100 have had a left neighbour we
checked does the array contain 99 the
easiest way to do this and the most
efficient way to do it is by taking our
initial array and converting it into a
set so now to find the start ranges
let's start iterating through our array
so we got we get to the first element
100 does it have a left neighbour well
we can check our set it doesn't have 99
in it so this is the first so this is
the start of a sequence so let's get the
length of the sequence we start at 100
now to get the length of the sequence we
want to count how many consecutive
numbers come after 100 so we want to
know does 101 exist in our sequence
looking at the number line obviously it
doesn't
how can we check this efficiently with
code well we already have a set that
takes up this entire array so let's just
use our set to check if 101 exists since
it doesn't we can no longer continue
this sequence so now we go we get to the
next number for is for the start of a
sequence let's look at our picture we
drove for is not the start of a sequence
and we can check this using our set we
would check that it does have a left
neighbor right three so it's not the
start of a sequence we're not going to
make a range from it we get to the next
number 200 is this the start of a
sequence looking at our picture yes it
is and we know that 199 does not exist
in our set so let's make this sequence
let's try to make it as long as we can
we check this 201 exists no it doesn't
we can tell that from our picture and we
would use the set to determine that so
now we'll this is as long as we can make
this set so let's get to the next number
one is one the start of a sequence at
our picture we can tell one does not
have a left neighbor so what is the
start of a sequence now let's check if
two exists in our set it does so we can
make this sequence a little bit longer
now let's check if the next number three
exists in our set yes it does so let's
make it even longer now does four exist
in our set yes it does
now let's check if five exists in our
set it doesn't right there is no there
is no 5 so we can't make this sequence
any longer so now let's continue through
the array 3 is to read the start of a
sequence no it's not it has a left
neighbor too now let's try 2 this 2 is
to the start of a sequence it's not
because it has a left neighbor 1 so we
went through the entire array we created
all the sequences we could the first
sequence is length 1 the second sequence
is also length 1
the third sequence is length 4 so this
is the longest sequence now we took a
really complicated problem or seemingly
complicated and we broke it down so
easily all we had to do is
iterate through the initial array use a
set and check if I've nodes had values
had left neighbors and if they didn't
then they were the start of sequences we
made this problem so easy with only
using one data structure since we only
had to iterate through the entire array
and we had to expand each range we know
that we're only going to visit each
number at most twice so our solution is
very efficient and we did have to use an
additional memory to create a set
because we wanted to check if neighbors
existed so we so for the memory
complexity it is also Big O of N in this
case n is the size of the input array so
now let's get to the code so we remember
we need to create a set from the initial
array nums
so it's really easy to do that in Python
we can just pass their D array into a
set constructor next we want to keep
track of what the longest consecutive
sequence is initially we can say it's 0
so we want to iterate through every
number in the number Rea and we want to
check if it's the start of a sequence
and we can check that simply by checking
if n minus 1 does not exist in our num
set if this number doesn't have a left
neighbour that means the start of a
sequence so now we want to get the
length of the sequence initially we can
say the length is 0 and we want to keep
getting each consecutive number and
checking if it exists in our num set if
it does then we can keep expanding the
length so initially I'm going to check n
plus lengths because that's going to
check the current number initially
length is 0 so we're just checking the
current number as it as the length grows
we'll check more consecutive numbers at
the end we could have potentially found
the longest sequence so we want to
potentially update our longest by just
taking the max of the current length we
just computed as well as what the
longest originally was
and it's really that simple so now all
we have left to do is just return what
the longest subsequence was that we just
computed so we did this in such a small
amount of code now let's just run it to
see that it works and it works perfectly
so this is a linear time solution in a
linear memory complexity solution once
we visualize the problem the solution
became so easy to derive